je suis de plus en plus excellent
orageuses au sud-ouest de la capitale
non il a encore tomber c'est mieux comme
ça que dois tu faire s'il y a une veille
de tornade et si l'abeille se transforme
en alerte
plusieurs violentes épisode orageux sont
attendus aujourd'hui
élevé de tornades potentiellement d'être
crise dites moi que je rêve ne t'en fais
pas pour ça mon chéri on va s'en sortir
on s'en sort toujours on s'en sortira
encore est ce que tu as plus
d'informations sur le parcours de la
tornade
elle fonce droit sur nous
si vous n'êtes pas à l'abri vous devez
vous y mettre immédiatement les allées
valeur de l'informatique
indiqué ce type la mer ne se produit
qu'une fois sur l'île
la population doit être sur ses gardes
et se préparer
paru
m
d
[Musique]